welcome to the section
on fitting classifiers by empirical risk
minimization
now this section is very much parallel
to our earlier section on regression
by empirical risk minimization
we have to really discuss two things in
order to do classification
and the first is how do you embed
categorical variables
b so we have uh script v
it's uh it's a finite set of possible
values of classes
that our target variable v can take
and we're going to take the target
variable v and
embed it into a vector y
in our m and we're going to let y be
psi of v and
of course psi of v only takes k values
as well
because v only takes k values and so we
have
psi we have capital k vectors
psi 1 through psi capital k
each of those are the images under the
map psi
of the classes v1 through vk
and we call these vectors psi
i the representative of v
i and the set of all
representatives i want to psi k is
called the constellation
of representatives some of some examples
we might embed true
to one and false to minus one
we might embed true to one and false to
zero
those are mappings from a
two element set of categories
into the real numbers
uh we might also map the three element
set
yes maybe no to the real numbers
one zero and minus one
another thing we might do is do a one
hot embedding
where we have say three
categories apple orange and banana
and um we met apple to
e1 orange to e2 and banana to e3
but e1 and e2 and e3 are the canonical
unit variables unit vectors in r3
now we might also take three categories
and map them directly to the reals
if we bought say three horses horse
three horse one and horse two
we might map them just to three one and
two
um well we might do really complicated
things like word to vec
which maps a large number of words two
vectors in r300
so the one hot embedding takes
k classes and maps into our k
so psi of vi is just e i
um we could do it to booleans if um
we have uh booleans where the
first representative maps to one zero
and the second
representative maps to zero one
um there's another version of the one
hot embedding called the reduced one hot
embedding
which maps one of the classes to
zero and the other k minus one classes
map to the unit vectors in our k
minus one um
so if we had booleans in that case that
reduces the mapping
uh uh
from the the one hot embedding it maps
the booleans to one zero
and zero one and the reduced one hot
embedding
would map the booleans to zero and one
a one dimensional embedding
rather than a two dimensional embedding
we might also have uh yes maybe no and
the default be maybe
in which case the that's three
categories
we would map it to r2 by the one hot
embedding the reduced one hot embedding
and we put maybe as the default so maybe
would map to the origin
yes might map to one zero and no might
map to zero
one
now once we've uh
embedded we are going to have to do
something we didn't have to do
uh in regression and that is unembed
uh and in particular we've got to
unembed uh
points which are not mapped to by our
embedding map
and um so we will see how to
do that
let's look at how this works from the
overall
predictor point of view so
we start off we embed our raw
input u to a feature vector x by the map
phi
the feature vector x lives in r d and
we've got a raw
output which is in our data set which is
a
v which is a categorical we map it to
psi of v
which is y which lives in rm
we use these data points we've gone from
n ui vi pairs to n x i
y i pairs and we use those to create a
predictor
g which maps r d to r m
and for any x it will give us a y hat
which lives in r
m and
now what are we going to do with y hat
well what we hope is that
uh um if y hat is g of x
then y is somehow close to psi
of v where v is one of the categories
um and close here would usually mean
in the norm so i've got uh
the norm of uh y
hat minus psi of v
is small for one of the v's
and to get the prediction we've got to
unembed we've got to
pick a v-hat
which is um uh
corresponding to the y hat and we're
going to define a map psi
dagger which takes vectors in our m
and maps them back into the target
set script v the unembedding function
so once we've got a psi dagger well we
can use it in order to construct our
final classifier
our final classifier has to take a u and
give us back a v
hat and the way it's going to work is
we're going to take u
pump it through our embedding phi to
give us an x
pump that through g to give us a
prediction y hat
and then pump that through the
unembedded psi dagger
to give us a v hat and then
we'll call that map from u to v hat
capital g mg is the composition
of psi dagger with g with phi in other
words we embed we predict
we aren't in bed
the usual unembedding that people choose
is the nearest neighbor on embedding
and what it does is it says well you've
got a y hat
pick out of all the categories in
script v the one such that psi of v
is the closest to y hat so minimize
over all little v's in script v the norm
of y hat minus psi of v
and that is called psi dagger of y hat
and if it so happens that there are two
vectors v two classes for which
uh their embedded points are equally
close to y
hat well then you can break ties any way
you want to
another way to say is what we're doing
is we're choosing the
target variable the target category
which is associated with the nearest
representative
to y hat
so here's the the simplest possible
example if we've
embedded the booleans true and false to
one
and minus one so those are our
representatives
psi one and psi two well then we would
unembed
by mapping any positive number
y hat to true and any
negative number y hat to false
because if we've got two representatives
which we have minus one and one
well if y hat is positive then the
closest representative
is one and if y hat is negative then the
closest representative is minus one
um suppose we've got one hot so let's
look at the
r2 case um
so here we have y one y
two two components of y we have
one zero and zero one
this will be psi one and this will be
psi two
those are the embeddings of our two
categories in the case of the booleans
so this would be
psi of true
and this would be psi of false
and then we develop a predictor and that
predictor
gives us back a y hat which is anywhere
in
the two-dimensional planes
and then what do we do well we'll say
if you're on this side of the plane
if y heads over there then uh
corresponding v hat will be psi one and
uh
if you're on this side of the plane then
the corresponding v hat will be psi two
and to be precise they will be not psi
one and psi two but
v one and v two the corresponding
targets true and false
um and so here it's clear all you do
is you look at the two components
of y hat y hat one and y hat two
and if y hat one is larger then you want
this side of the plane
you're on this side of the plane and if
y2 is larger well then you're on this
side
of the boundary between the two between
the which to separates the region
which belongs to psi one in the region
that belongs to side two
let's put it another way if
y hat one is greater than y hat two
um then
the arg min over
v of the norm
of psi v minus
y hat
is ah
is v1
otherwise it's v2
this is true more generally
if we want to find out which is what is
the solution in general
to this problem of iron embedding what
is ci dagger when we've used the one hot
embedding
um it turns out that this is exactly
what we think it is we look at the
largest
component of the vector y hat
and uh we
return the corresponding target
vector so if y hat 3
is the largest component of y hat
then our unembedding psi dagger would
return
v3 and the reason for that we can just
work out algebraically what
it is if i look at what
what y hat minus e i
is um well that's the
two norm squared of that quantity is the
two norm of y
hat plus one uh minus two y hat
transpose e
i and y hat transpose e i
is just y hat i
it's just the i component of y hat and
so
picking i
to minimize that quantity
is precisely the same as picking i to
maximize
y hat i
um suppose we've embedded a reduced
one hot embedding we've used the reduced
one hot embedding
to embed yes maybe no as one zero
zero zero or zero one well then we
unembed
in exactly the same way for any point
y hat in the r2 plane
we pick the closest representative and
that tells us which target variable
we're predicting so if
y hat is over here in this region
it's i'm going to return yes
yes is psi dagger of any point in that
region
no is psydagger of any point in this
and maybe a cy dagger of any point in
the remaining region
and that's nicely expressed in the
little cases construction there
and again you can choose any value you
like on the boundary
so more generally we might um have
an embedding of
categories into r m
and that gives us a whole bunch of
different representatives
they're represented by these blue dots
and for any given point y-hat in
our m we want to find the closest
representative and the way we do that
is by the voronoi diagram that we saw
earlier
and so in particular
this region right here
is the set of points
for which the closest blue dot is
that one in the middle and so that means
that if y hat is in that region
i will return the corresponding
representative
to that blue dot right there and as
we've seen when we looked at the nearest
neighbor classifier
the regions which
correspond to each target variable or to
each representative
a polyhedra
now suppose we're using a parameterized
predictor so
g is a function of a parameter theta
and g is might be theta transpose times
x if it's a linear predictor it might be
something more complicated well then c
does the parameter we choose
and then once we've got a predictor
g theta we can we compose it with
the embedding psi and the unembedding
the embedding this should be the
embedding phi let's just
see that we use that same notation here
this that should be phi
so this should say psi dagger
g theta phi
of u
not psi of u and that's the classifier
that gives us v-hat
so what do we do we choose theta using
erm
in a training data set and we validate
the predictor
by looking at the performance matrix
which might be
the error rate on a test data set
of course the performance metric might
be the name and person
error measure as well
and so when we're doing parametrized
predictors for classification we might
use
a tree based predictor that's got a name
it's very commonly used it's called a
classification tree
and then theta encodes the tree tells us
when to split at each node and the
threshold and leaf values
and each leaf has a corresponding value
of y-hat
and that leads immediately to a
corresponding target
because we can unembed the y-hat to
the v-hat and we might use a neural
network
um in which case theta gives us the bias
or the offset and the weights in the
different layers
and then y hat is the output of the last
layer and again we unembed
we might use a linear predictor theta is
a d
by m matrix and y
hat is just theta transpose times x
now the other major piece that we need
for classification is a loss function
and it turns out that the loss function
uh that we would use for classification
is slightly different from the typical
loss function we would use
for regression and we're going to see in
the next section
several different loss functions for
classifiers
now for the moment i want to consider
the simplest
loss function and that's
for example the square loss now the way
it works
is just like it did in regression
is that we have a loss function this is
not quite right it should be the loss
function
maps r m cross r
m to r
and it's a function of y hat and y and
it tells us how much prediction
y hat bothers us when the true
observed value of y is what it is
and it's going to be of course one of
the representatives
those are the only possible values for y
because the only possible values for v
are v one through v k and when we embed
those we get psi one through psi k
as a result we can think about loss
functions slightly
differently rather than thinking about a
loss function
as taking a y hat and a y
we can say well really what we have is
we have k different
loss functions the first one
is the loss function which tells us how
much loss
y hat causes us
when the target variable is
v1 that's l of y hat psi
one or when the target variable is v two
then we get a different loss and we'll
think of that as a totally different
loss function
and we might even param we might even
use this kind of notation
uh l sub j of y
hat to say well actually we've got
a different loss function for
j is 1 up to capital k
and this last function only depends
on y hat because the dependency on y
is taken care of by j
what it is is it's how much we dislike
predicting y
hat in the particular case where the
target variable is v
j or correspondingly when y is psi j
and typically what you want is you want
that the last function
l of y hat psi j is a non-negative
number and it's small when y hat is
close to psi
j so very commonly we might use the
square loss
which is the two norm of y hat minus psi
j
um we'll see other loss functions which
work
much better for classification in the
next section
so how do we think about two different
loss functions when we're using the
square loss in the boolean case
well they're translated versions of the
quadratic function
this is on the on the right here
is l of y hat y
when y is psi
2 and psi 2 is just 1.
and this is l on the left here of y hat
and y
when y is psi one
which is just minus one and we can see
that the one on the right is a quadratic
centered at one
and the one on the left is a quadratic
centered at minus one
so we're given a training data set
x i y i pairs for i is one up to n
and we've got a parameterized predictor
g theta
and empirical risk minimization simply
says well what we do
is we minimize the average
loss function over theta where
the loss is evaluated
at y hat i and y i and y hat i is just
our prediction
evaluated at x i
so erm chooses theta to minimize the
loss
regularized drm chooses the theta to
minimize
the empirical risk plus lambda times the
regularization function
and lambda here is a positive
regularization hyperparameter
and in most cases we're going to need to
do numerical optimization to find theta
there won't be an explicit formula
now in the least squares case it's quite
interesting let's consider what that is
in the boolean case
so in the boolean case let's have
u be
one dimensional just to make
it easy for me to draw and let's be v
have
v be either true or false
and we'll embed true to one
so this will be psi of true
and this will be psi
of false
and at each of our data points
will give us a value of u and a
corresponding
value of
um of
b which will embed to give us a one or a
minus one
so we might have a bunch of data points
here and
a bunch of data points here
and that's our data points and then what
we're going to do is we're going to fit
that with least squares
so we're going to say use linear
predictor y
hat is theta transpose x and that will
fit
a straight line right there
now because we're unembedding using sai
dagger psy dagger here remember
is the inverse is the
unembedding map corresponding to
the one hot embedding and so it's going
to say well whenever
y hat is positive your prediction
should be true and whenever y is
negative your prediction should be false
and if uh
line the the
plot of our predictor theta transpose x
happens to be like this
that means that whenever uh
u is over to the right here
i project true and whenever u is over to
the left here
i put it false
and if we look at our data we can see
well that in my simple sketch there
didn't seem to do too badly
although it's an astonishing idea that
we can fit a function that only takes
values
one and minus one with a straight line
this is called a least squares
classifier
we're using a square loss we might be
using a square regularizer
and we just solve the rerm problem and
this is the case where we can solve it
exactly using least squares
as an example in two dimensions and we
see that it
it kind of works and so here i've got u
is an r2
it's embedded in r3
as one u1 u2 remember we've got the
constant
feature and we've embedded minus 1
1 just directly as y
is minus 1 or y is 1 as our two
representatives
psi 1 is -1 side 2 is one
we use a square loss and a square
regularizer
and these are our predictor this is our
predictor the shading here
shows which points
you want you to map to
1 and which points map to -1
and of course really what's going on is
that
this here this boundary
that's the boundary where y hat is zero
and y
hat is a linear function of u one u two
y hat
we know what it must look like y hat
must be equal
to theta 1 plus theta 2 u1
plus theta 3 u2
and this line right here is the u ones
and u twos
which result in y hat being zero
over on this side we have y hat
positive and over on this side we have y
hat negative and
our unembedding maps that
to one and minus one to give us a
classifier
now if we have the name and pearson
metric
so the name and pearson metric remember
what it is it says we're going to
consider
a weighted sum of the different errors
where ej is the rate of mistaking vj for
some other class
and kappa here is going to be the weight
so kappa j is how much we care about
mistaking vj about predicting the answer
in the case where the true target
variable is vj
wrong and what we do is we scale
the losses by kappa
so suppose we have loss functions
we've seen already the square lofts
which we'll call
l tilde y hat
well then l tilde y hat psi j for
example
might be the square loss it might be
the square of y hat minus psi j
or it might be the norm of y hat minus
psi j squared
well then we'll construct a loss
function from these unweighted losses
by taking a weighted combination of
these losses so we will use a loss
function
l of y psi j which is kappa j
times l tilde of y and psi j
so let's look at an example suppose i've
got psi one is minus one
and psi two is one we're going to care
about the name and pearson metric
now because this is boolean there are
two types of errors we can make
the false negatives and the false
positives and our name and pearson
metric is going to be kappa
times the false negative rate plus the
false positive rate
kappa some number positive greater than
zero
um notice here that we've only got one
scalar kappa
whereas on the previous slide we had the
number of scalar kappas equal to number
of categories and so we really should
have
kappa 1 times efn plus kappa 2 times efp
and here of course kappa is simply kappa
one divided by kappa two if you like
because um
i can set one of the kappas to one
and all that matters is the ratio of the
two kappas
in terms of affecting which prediction i
get
now our last function we're going to use
the square loss but we're going to scale
it
and so we'll use y hat minus y squared
when y is minus 1.
we'll use kappa times y hat minus y
squared
when y is 1. and that will give us
a weight which is greater
when the true
y is one and so we want to make sure
that we are penalizing here
false negatives more than false
positives
here's an example so square loss sum of
squares regularizer
now this on the left here is the
roc curves and they
correspond to minimizing
the weighted sum kappa
efn plus efp and
these are the two losses the training
losses in blue and the test losses in
red
on the right hand plot over here we see
the minimum error classifier
which is given by when kappa is one and
that would correspond
to
this point down here
now if we pick kappa's .4 well then
we're
very concerned to make sure that we
don't mistake
any red points for blue points and we
end up with a classifier
that has moved the boundary in this
direction
conversely if we pick kappa is 4
well then we're very concerned to make
sure we don't mistake
any blue points as red points until we
move the boundary
in this direction and by varying kappa
we will vary our preference for
what type of errors we're willing to
tolerate
so let's summarize a classifier is a
predictor
when the raw output is categorical
we have categories v one through v k
when k is two it's called a boolean
classifier when k is greater than two
it's called a multi-class classifier
and we might have various error rates
summarized in a confusion matrix
now when we're fitting a classifier to
training data
via erm or regularized drm
we embed the raw output v into rm
using psi the
vectors psi 1 through psi k are then
the embeddings of our targets v1 through
vk
we now use erm to build a predictor for
y
we unembed to get y um
our predictor will give us a y hat which
we can unembed
to get a class prediction v hat
we do this by nearest neighbor on
embedding
next section we will talk about special
loss functions for classifiers